thank you to everyone for sticking with
us I know we always have some attrition
on the second days people have flights
to catch and other things to take care
of but thank you for sticking around
we've got John Roberts who has a PhD in
theoretical high-energy physics with ten
years of research experience in
high-energy particle physics and
ultra-high energy cosmic rays obviously
he now works as the senior vice
president of data Sciences and audience
development for about.com where he leads
a team of researchers deriving insights
for more than 20 years of internet data
across thousands of topics and I can
also vouch for the fact that he gives a
really good explanation of why but we
believe there's dark matter so you may
want to follow up with him afterwards
thank you very much for speaking this
talk will be relatively quick I think
and there's going to cover a few
different things because my back of my
current position is a little different
too many people in the room a lot of
what we've heard about over the course
of the last day and a half our data
processors data systems and the
management curation use of data inside
companies that are pretty heavily and
easily described as data-driven or data
companies themselves I currently work in
digital media it would be a enormous
stretch to claim the digital media is a
data-driven organization or a data based
company and as mentioned to a few people
last night when I first joined the
company after leaving physics I met the
CEO who'd seen my resume but no idea oh
you're dark matter why did we hire you
and that was kind of the attitude coming
into a digital media company but for
myself but also for a number of other
people who I know in New York or doing
data science and what I'm going to talk
to you about today there is actually one
of the the uses of the data that we have
and and taking on an industry that's
actually specifically not data-driven
taking on some of the perspectives and
beliefs that that industry holds with
the data that we have at hand and so
there's going to talk about about
personalization I'll cover some of the
ways in which we use date of the date
that we have and have that data comes to
be in the company
if the clicker works I'll sure that it
does that would be the matter thank you
there we go okay so this is all about
the promise of personalization right so
the promise of personalization is that
if we can collect all the data from all
the places about all the things that you
do that everything you read about every
action you take online we can give you
the most relevant recommendations for
you if you internet is a large place
there's a lot of things you can do on
there there is no way any one person to
just jump into the internet type in a
URL at random and assume you're going to
get something good it's a it's a inter
itself is he big data problem the future
this engenders in the ones that were all
very familiar with our and this isn't
true just of the internet but it's true
very broadly across what the data sets
that we've been talking about over the
last couple of days Google and Facebook
know everything about me amazon falls me
around the internet ad networks are
taking my data and selling it around the
web with that renewing there's this shot
of the doors close the windows stop
people taking my data attitude to what's
going on so if we're going to try and
deliver on this promise of we're only
doing it for your good we're only trying
to fight those data to give you a
relative information we have to be damn
sure that we're actually doing that now
if we're talking about BuzzFeed trying
to give you more relevant content that's
one thing but at about we just launched
the fourth largest consumer health site
in the u.s. in April right it's really
important if we're tracking that kind of
information to make sure that firstly
we're abiding by both the left in the
spirit of every law that relates to that
information but also that we make sure
that anything that we do with that 18
recommendation we provide off it is
right I getting it wrong in that area is
a really bad idea so this is kind of
utopian at line as its kind of written
in the panels are kind of digital media
at the moment but you take however you
look at everything you click everything
you read you build up a profile of a
person a user redrawn the enzyme which
really is the profile of a unique user
ID like a user on a device and say ok
this device tends to do these things and
go to these places and read this content
and behave in this kind of way and so
from that you can infer or you should be
able to infer age gender household
income interest profiles all of that
information that gives you a reasonably
well rounded picture of who a person is
and then use that information to provide
more relevant recommendations get people
easier paths inside a site or between
size to get to the content that you
expect them to want and and also
inevitably on the flip side of this to
give them adds that they're more likely
to be interested in or engaged with or
be more aggressive as an advertiser to
some people because they're high value
targets but you got all those various
pieces in there so this is the division
of personalization which is pursued by a
lot of digital media companies it is
absolutely the version of
personalization that is pursued by a
large number of at and ad tech companies
this is really coming back just because
of the profusion of user level turkey
level data that exists in the world and
this is precisely why the internet is
slow right loading a page of text is
incredibly fast the organization in the
world that causes the most delay in the
Internet is google google runs the attic
changes google as all this behavior tab
when an ad loads is not an ad loading as
an ad and three or four or five or a
hundred or 200 individual scripts that
are coming along with it all pull data
at your cookies and off your page and
send it back to the various change
advertised in the back end google runs
out at exchange and that exchange slows
then everything is happening on the page
without yet exchange the page is very
quick that's actually one of the reasons
that wikipedia is actually super quick
and has enormous engagement stats that
nobody else will ever meet google also
prioritizes page speed as a signal of
quality and strength and ranking the
algorithms so you can see the version of
google
I think Google take it away in this
particular ecosystem so the question we
were asking was does this even make
sense right can we actually do this is
this actually a solvable problem in our
particular world and you can ask it more
broadly around the internet but for our
world as a content provider as a
publisher on the internet should we be
doing individual user level personalized
recommendations it seems like a great
idea where yet we have millions of
pieces of content across thousands of
topics it's not sensible to assume the
user is going to be able to navigate
their way through that without some very
heavy guidance so we have to my team
specifically my team has to build the
recommendation algorithms the infinite
scroll algorithms the search algorithms
to help people navigate a corpus of
content at that size so first question
if we go back to this utopian model
either go from step one step two right
so question one is can you can you
actually use an interest profile and use
a bigger on the Internet to infer age
gender household income even an interest
profile the second step is once you've
got all the demographic information can
you actually get to something useful can
you get a better idea what people are
likely to want to read and we can test
it we have a lot of data so we did test
it and we have a wonderful laboratory to
do it and so this is the reason why 20
year old internet company that hadn't
had anything done to tour 2012 now as
five PhDs across a range of subjects
from astrophysics to neuroscience to
computational linguistics because this
is the data set and we get to look at it
first this data set is about since
january first 2000 now about and you've
almost certainly all been there you
usually will likely go there once a
month you'll go for completely disparate
questions across different topics you'll
get there by searching google you'll
click a link somewhere in the top five
or ten links and you'll go to the page
and you'll forget that it was about that
UNT and we have studied and checked all
of have information
there are good reasons that why that's
the case is also good reasons why we're
taking steps to change that but a bank
ranks for about one in three of all
queries that are typed into the intent
maybe the top 100 results we rank top 10
for a significant fraction of that and
have done for a very long time and a bat
has always written content to cover more
or less any questions that we have felt
with the company's felt needs answered
actually the way they've done this is an
interesting and feel unique way which is
that you have individual subdomains or
had individual submarines which cover
any topic that we felt was interesting
and then we got a writer that we hired
on as a freelancer to go write about
that topic and we didn't tell them what
to write we just let them have at it so
this is the federally 20 years
idiosyncratic expertise about all things
and I use the word idiosyncratic
advisedly having done NLP on this corpus
he finds some very interesting patterns
and outliers when you do that I'll tell
you about a few of them later and but
what you see here is the vertical axis
is traffic so this number of pages
coming to the sights on a particular
month right and and the horizontal axis
is time so the beginning of january
first 2000 the end I think it was 2014
when we made this plot and every single
band of color here is one of those
subdomains one of those thousand topics
right so there's this this is the strata
of interest on a bat and you see the
macroscopic trends it gets larger over
time at the in turn out got larger over
time that more less went with it that's
not surprising and you see the peaks and
troughs in the total volume you see
there's kind of wonderful double peak
that comes in regularly that's november
and january right that's the heartbeat
of the entire site because everyone gets
off the internet in december and talks
to their family which is a very good
thing for the world and but in the
summer you see a big drop as people go
outside and get sunshine which is also a
very good thing for the world and
and in here you have Olympics you have
presidential elections we have four of
them I think in our data set and so we
can track the trans around presidential
elections and and you can see lots of
things with your regular patterns and
many things that are irregular patterns
right so an example here you can see the
green little green daggers in that
central band that's within our travel
content and it's a little triangle of
diary which is a topic only spikes in
October and it's big enough to move
traffic on the scale of the entire
network of a bat right this is big
enough to be visible when you're looking
at the whole history of this site it
turns out that's our good New England
site and that's explicitly leaf-peeping
I people going to watch leaves in New
England is big enough to move something
which is a reasonable representation of
the USS internet interest the brown
blobs of the bottom here are actually
coincide with US military action I
highly irregular and a pig occur and
these two points and then UCF you later
on and turns out that's our political
humor site we have a US military site we
have PTSD site we have military family
content and we've US military career
content we have foreign policy content
none of those spiked to the same extent
when you look at this plot as US
military humor the country when the
country goes to war wants to read jokes
and have a bit of a light-hearted laugh
about it and get a break and yet also
are interested in the military action we
saw two spikes in September 2001 one is
our Islam site the US suddenly wanted to
learn a lot about Islam very quickly the
other one was in our weight loss site we
haven't done a really detailed analysis
of this but the running theory inside
the group is that this is the biggest
January first wake up call you have to
go on a diet and get fit but the country
has ever been given and it actually
relaxes in roughly the same way if you
look at that the pattern that falls off
afterwards and but as a reaction to
domestic terrorism or terrorism on
domestic soil and it is remarkable that
answer thousands of topics that could
have spiked
that point those were the only two who
did and with massive significance hey so
that does kind of a quick trip tight
about what it covers each of these as a
particular vertical as well the
different broad colors are and and we
can use the tilaka trends across the
internet with across the last 20 years
we can see the breadth and depth of
various technologies we have a palm
pilot site well should we had hits can
you see it declining you see it's lunch
get me anything by the cell phone and
the cell phone gets eaten by the the
iphone and then you see the tablet
coming and easy trends and religion over
time and the huge benefit of this is and
that basically didn't redesign its site
for like a decade the New York Times
posited that stayed pretty much static
so it gives you a perfectly static
laboratory in which to analyze relative
interest in topics over time it's also
important that the site is drawn by
evergreen search queries so it is not
that this interest is driven by what's
ever puts on the homepage the homepage
whoo back gets no traffic because nobody
actually chooses to go to a bat as a
brand and go there to learn what's
happening so this is actually a pretty
good definitional tracking of the
breadth of google searches Bing searches
in other ways in which people can get to
that content so taking that can we
assume for a demographic data off the
back of it if we have a laboratory like
this can we use it to try and figure out
who you are we have over a million
documents with evergreen interest we
have demographic data from Google and
Facebook we I don't trust either of them
I also don't trust their data but that's
a different question and so we
cross-check them against each other we
find out that actually given the both of
them have sources of first-party data
sorrel ion they're not interfering EU
are like you have a Google+ profile
where you typed in your age where we
have a facebook profile which has a
whole bunch of information about you and
until we cross imma get to cross-check
them against each other and find that
they agree extremely well in the broad
aggregate we're good they don't give you
into users but will give us buckets
right
now we can currently about topic
interest with demographics and we can
start asking questions ran does the
content you read infer something about
your demographics does your demographic
and first something about the topics
that you're likely to read and so one of
the questions that invite our sales team
at and many other people in the company
can we understand Millennials or please
God tell me how to understand
Millennials which was this specific
question in this one and which we
slightly rephrased is what interest /
index for Millennials because we are
scientists after all and so here's an
example right and it's it's actually a
surprisingly simple thing to do and it's
even though the content that we have is
large the like event level data that
gets fired off when somebody comes the
visits the site is a very large the
profiles of interest by demographic is a
very small data set right you have a
very finite set of demographics you care
about you will find that set of topics
and you have new over and under index
that you can go build off the back of
that by looking at average interest
versus expected traffic so for example
is 18 to 24 year old guys the black line
would be the average rat user and then
the green bars are where that particular
demographic lies compared to the average
about user right we simple calculations
but highly informative the ordered list
here is military career sports korea's
musicians film and TV careers which is
in the military they're just being rock
stars and just being actors
it's fabulous although to be careful the
answer really here is if somebody is
interesting going into the military or
acted like they're over-indexing
unlikely to being an 18 to 24 year old
male not that all agent went for your
mails care about this as soon as you
move up over 25 the film and TV curator
disappears it drops way down the list
and now they really want to go into
sales which is an interesting learning
and educational to our sales team you
wanted to ask the question in the first
place and then we can go into into
individual topics and look at the change
in interest over time so millennia woman
it turns out or three times more
interested in reading Matt going to
Paris the normal am your woman it turns
out millennial men are exactly as
uninterested in going to Paris is not
male me on the head and this this
started scare interesting if I go okay
now we're actually learning some
interesting things and it's not like
we're short of statistics we have
massive data sets we have hundreds of
thousands millions tens of millions of
people coming through these sites and
and so the point where we started to say
that a whole bunch of astrophysicists
and nerdy neuroscientist and competition
linguistics inside the 20 year old
internet company were giving the entire
millennial population of the US dating
advice that started to get a little
intriguing it opens up a whole new
business model and conveniently we are
in the same company as match we did not
go there
and but then you start looking it's in
health right you can effectively see
your future life laid out in front of
you because you can go decade by decade
and look at the predictive health
interests of every demographic segment
as you get older that's fascinating
interesting but in terms of Millennials
18 to 24 is team health eating disorders
addiction schizophrenia agnese STDs
phobias contraception social anxiety
disorder all highly significant spikes
some of these clearly age-related right
you need to learn about teen health when
you're a teenager you need there's
obviously a higher spike and it just
eating disorders of that age as well
STDs and contraception are kind of
obvious but schizophrenia social anxiety
disorder another stress related
conditions should not necessarily spike
for the under 25 if you've ever watched
girls the TV show they hit the nail on
the head they basically all suffer from
most of these things on some level and
it just means that you know Lena done
got it right she read the mind of her
generation very precisely if you go up
to 24 to 35 suddenly the interest slip
completely about breastfeeding pregnancy
miscarriage preemies infertility
multiples again not surprising that it's
interesting to see was like it's always
nice when you look at a dataset and you
see the obvious things stand out like a
sore thumb like okay good like we've
derived the obvious thing and and the
millennial health interests are just the
same as everyone else also reminded us
in the mind of the sales team that
Millennials are actually 25 to 35 as
well the very young and their young
families right which is something I
think we often forget Apple about
Millennials edge attainment topics this
was fun one a woman really high
interested under 24 in short stories as
the most productive interest of you
being a woman under 24 and then manga TV
dramas young adult books can tap it
performing arts R&B funk music and
romance novels men into animate so there
is an anime manga divided between the
genders under 24 and wrap then manga
sell celebrity gossip sci-fi pro
wrestling which is alarmingly high in
interest and has been for a long time
punk music dance music war movies horror
and animated TV and so the advice from
this one is that guys should we do not
war two and talk to girls about it this
is not new it is but it is extremely
statistically significant within our
data which was fabulous and news and
issues right there in an election year
we've obviously been tracking the
interested in various political topics
through our data sets over the course of
the last year everyone turns into
demographic data for Millennials it
turns out that under 24 year olds and
the 25 year olds really care about
foreign policy actually the number one
thing that turns up they care about for
involving more than any other
demographic segment and there is
journalism liberal politics not shorting
you can actually see the transition from
liberal to conservative with decade of
life you can also see it in the religion
content and terrorism interestingly race
relations civil liberties animal rights
the economy I which again was little
surprising women's issues environmental
issues in the Middle East some of these
very issues very cause basis not new
news right this is the generation which
everyone has come to realize now is a
highly cause driven generation but to
have them also really interested in
predictively interested in over-indexing
for interest in the economy and foreign
policy and highlights there's a slightly
more serious-minded generation we might
have given them credit for and also
being interested women's rights is a
better predictor of your age than your
gender which I see is a very positive
feature for the future in total
particularly with the way this year's
politics was going and we can do this
with even more granularity we can go
inside an individual topic area we can
say within the topic of Christianity and
also our Islam sides what is the most
predictive or one of the top three most
predictive topics of being a guy under
24 and i'll let you I'm not going to ask
anybody to call that answers I'm not
going to do that in this session not at
this point of the afternoon but you can
just keep in your head where you think
the guesses because it turns out this is
actually true for both the Islam and the
cushion certain this is us audience u.s.
guys under 24 turns out is whether or
not the religion allows them to get it
to two which is rather fabulous I one of
the top three things they always like
the Illuminati conspiracy and I forget
the third so okay so we've pretty much
sure that we can connect what you read
about what you care about what you want
to read about with your demographics
right you there are predictive signals
here of your age and the things that
people of your age engender tend to be
interested in and we can line those up
so we can from demographic segment say
here's a probability distribution of
things you may be interested in like
that we enter the level of the cancer
graphicriver full probability matrix
across that by age and gender and if we
see really piece of content we can also
do the opposite direction say I have a
probability measure across the
demographics of which demographic you
may be and obviously I can iterate on
that is read more content to build up a
profile of you that way and start to get
a better better better estimation of the
agent ND you may be at so we've had
success i resolve that first p so the
problem we have a way of getting that
first piece linked up but we look at
this more broadly and more widely
there's a very particular trend that
stood out which was really it's one of
its surprising when you first look at it
and then when you look at it again you
go
oh no okay that's actually kind of
sensible so the most predictive topic of
a woman's age the most predictive
interest of a woman's age I actually
topic to relate to the person for whom
she cares I results in the money but its
fertility content I pregnancy content
and then it weaves into baby health ADHD
child parenting family cooking family
should have all of that content going up
through the ages and then at 45 it
switches over to that the Alzheimer's
and Parkinson's and assisted living
become predictively being a woman 45 to
55 that's obviously not about you that's
about the people for whom you care about
the fact that prostate cancer is a
predictive interest of you being an
older woman was the thing that really
stood out okay now if you take a very
rough approach to this new you say okay
you're reading this content so you're
obviously the person who would read this
content you would say that that woman at
45 was a schizophrenic teenager who just
happened to be a bizarre sufferer
prostate cancer who was also going
through chronic depression right the the
portfolio of interest actually does not
line up to an individual person it lines
up to a set of people right but it's
also true that if you were to take that
person right every time they came to
your site and assume that that person
will have the same bag of interest that
they'd show in the last time they will
also be wrong woman on the inside is we
have understood them are most accurately
described by all of the different people
for whom they care about at least they
are multiple people and likely every
time they come to your site they're
going to display as a different person
men terrifyingly are predicted by the
toys that they play with another to
consistently to video games cars faster
cars cars without a roof
powerboats and classic motorcycles in
the 45 to 55 then over 65 if you really
met model trains you are pretty much
guaranteed to be a man over 65 and I'm
not going straight to our entertainment
content to get that advertising of all
topics of literally all topics which are
the ones that / index the most for a
guy's age and it is terrifying retrieve
that it is toys at every decade of life
yeah we were both like horrified and yea
mostly horrified we ran through this
particular exercise well there is
obviously there's a very way we can see
midlife crises just like right there
it's really blindingly obvious when when
when midlife crisis jumps up like oh
really oh okay it's also the age of
which in the health content men go from
caring about running to caring about
walking this is a straight transition at
45 from running to get exercise to walk
into get exercise and at that point all
our futures just lay that in front of us
and so that proves is a fundamental
challenge to this model right which is
saying that we were trying to understand
one individual person provide one
profile of one person and we basically
come out against fifty percent of the
population who do not consistently
behave as one person they consistently
behave as being interested in very
specific different topics and it's okay
well what about the other signals we've
got maybe we can get a tighter read on
this by taking it to camp camp things
aren't just the content like to the
coming from email do they come in from
social media are they doing very
particular things so people like through
from email tend to be older email skews
old on the interview will come from
search SQ older but organic search these
younger and then people who reach the
side from Facebook tend to skew like 35
to 45 that's more or less the median age
of Facebook it's actually not a
millennial platform as anybody with kids
who use snapchat walnut
and but we can people browse more in
favorite different content movie date
that's consistently true we see much
higher engagement on a week ends in a
weekday and they read differently when
people come from facebook that tends to
20 times more likely to share to
Facebook right so they they are very
different patterns when they come in
from facebook so we have some very
predictive defining features in our data
set but it turns out these predictive
features have got nothing to do with who
you are it is not the case that the
person comes from Facebook always comes
in from facebook that's the same person
you just have to come a facebook but
when they came for facebook the likely
to share to Facebook a lot more than
they did when they came in from an email
or from search so you are a different
person when you come in from facebook I
do this is your users behavior on
Facebook and this is your usage behavior
not on Facebook to paraphrase the old
PSA and people who come to decide that
we can read more content and browse more
when you're in your weekend mindset you
but you behave utterly differently from
how you do during the week that you are
a different person you behave
differently so here you are like who you
are long-term who you are in total is a
small perturbation on top of the
definition of who you are right now
right and this is the thing that the ad
agencies have got fundamentally wrong
because they want to get a they want to
collect all the data that all things
about you right now and then they want
to just hammer you the same message over
and over and over again based on that
information rather than privilege in the
fact that they have no idea what what
what you're doing on the internet right
now what the top of your mind anybody is
being pursued around the internet by ad
following you knows that this is true
all right amazon has made a decision
that you're going to buy this thing even
though you only looked at it once and
they're not going to let you go for a
week until you've decided to actually
buy the thing but think about the other
way how many times have you tried to buy
a present for a niece and nephew and an
aunt or uncle or cousin like you go on
your by the pair's by present for them
every year every year you'll have no
idea what eight-year-old nine-year-old
ten-year-old boys are into this year and
Emmas
knows you're buying for somebody's not
you because they know where you send it
right they've got the address you sent
it they've got the name of the person
they can predict the visitor by they
know that you bought this for them every
year or of this at roughly the same time
and they know what boys want to play
with this year would it not be useful
for Amazon to privilege the fact that
you're not you today you're actually
looking for another person and give you
the suggestions for your nephew the day
you come to Amazon is that not something
we would all use we'd happily be
personalized as somebody else on that
day the last point here is actually
interesting so one of the biggest
challenges with personalization is
getting enough information to really
build up a profile of a person it's
fundamentally difficult right you're
saying that a few data points kappa
reverse at a month is going to get you
enough information to really understand
somebody what we're saying here is
actual you really need to know is where
you came from today what device you're
on and what's the content you're reading
well we're trying to say like we'll go
from the content you reading will infer
your age and gender and then we'll come
back from that a contender to generally
understand what people who are
stereotypically like you because let's
not kid ourselves what I just ran
through earlier and this is darius i
find out we're looking at broad bucket
trends what tend to like this content we
would be providing the most
stereotypical biased insight as to what
you're likely to want to read next
rather than saying you're on a piece of
content around caring for a parent with
prostate cancer you probably want to
read more content about that right now
irrespective of who you are because
right now you are a person who cares for
a person who has this condition and by
having the hubris to believe that we can
understand you through a few sets of
pages that have been read over the
course of the last month or a couple of
months or a year and therefore assume
better than you telling us everything
you're telling us right now what you
want to read about this attack ularly
arrogant we try to it fails horribly as
well which is getting it
so here's the utopian outline but its
effects right this completely ignore the
middle inference step why not go
straight from looking at what you're on
right now and then telling you what you
should read right now you actually don't
need to go through that middle step the
the categorical is being made here is
assuming that we ever could do that
intermediate step and then even if we
could do that intermediate step that it
would help us so what do we do treat
people right now is you need people I
don't look at a long baseline history of
what they've done before because it's a
very poor predictor I rank signals that
are predictive of behavior and build a
pejorative recommendation system right
we basically know what the ordered list
of signals are likely to tell you what
you want to read next based on the
things that we know literally right now
this is important because when you're
building recommendation systems and we
we've talked a lot about the speed with
which data has to be available to make a
decision on a recommendation system has
to do in under 100 milliseconds nice you
have to book access process and return
the data in a very very very small
window of time you have to do it at
massive scale right you're doing this
for hundreds of thousand ten thousand
million people coming through it aside
to give an amount of time like this has
to be quick so content first if you're
on a piece of content and it's a fun
reference ID right for a bat if you're
on a reference site you've come in your
landlord piece of content that solves a
problem for you we that tells us what
the problem is that you're trying to
solve and then it we should know what
content falls on from that that gives a
list of 10 20 30 things we could put
next then you iterate over that list
take source of traffic people from
facebook like some stuff people like the
ones is the weekend or not that tells
whether it's more browser you're more
focused time of day time a week if
somebody's coming to our new health side
very well which we launched in April and
it's the middle of the night and they're
on their cell phone and it's on a piece
of content about first aid then we
shouldn't
around and try and tell you the 10 click
years things that bandages that you need
to know this week we should tell you how
to fix the thing that you're coming into
and give you all sorts of to find it if
it's not there so how we actually build
the content recommendation system to get
into a little bit more detail so add
metadata although all documents a
document is a useless thing until you
can quantify and turn it into a set of
numbers simplest thing of CTF IDF like a
text frequency but build the text
frequency and a document for you based
on the corpus you're preparing to and it
turns out the word carbon fiber is not
that informative composite site but it's
really really important when you're
looking at another site doesn't use the
word all the time entity extraction pool
is that because entities times dates
locations build a vector of entities for
every document that gives you a very
information rich and very sparse vector
for every document that allows you to do
some really interesting things and
reading grade level is actually really
informative right it just tells you
whether it's simple or complex
information people are reading
information that's more as
straightforward has the lower grade
level tends to flow into lower grade
level content if somebody's looking at
more expert content within a site that
will have a higher grade levels you can
use it substitute for expertise which is
interesting you don't want to be giving
somebody on technical site 101 content
if they're really at a much higher
expertise level which will show in the
grade level and you can use these
features to build a text distance
between documents right there are lots
of ways to build it offers feature set
like this you iterate over things that
are working you use your readers to tell
you what works and you run the
experiment iteratively until you get to
a set of features that are relatively
stable you probably want to do this for
you to the different sections of the
content you're working with because a
recommendation engine is built for a
food site is going to need a different
set of parameters around all these
things than on a health site then on a
wellness or fitness or nutrition site
layer on separate distant measures for
documents on top of just the text level
ones we have user co-occurrence might
renew the same users come in twice they
come to two different sets of documents
we know that across all the million
documents we have so the user care
accounts between documents gives the
distance measure just from users
directly to us utterly irrespective of
the actual text similarity measures so
it gives the second orthogonal measure
of document distance and and only use
landing page this likelihood time people
started on this page because if you do
with all the pages they read then you're
just going to reproduce your own
recommendation engine in your own data
and that was horribly circular and then
served as well as this is search engine
results pages so if this content and
stuff on these pages alongside these
other domains and another URL tends to
turn up a very similar domain list that
gives you a similarity measure from the
mind of google it's always useful you
can pick the mind of google it's
cheating that they cheat too and they're
bigger than I am so I will steal their
homework and as a result of this you get
a distance between every piece of
content so this is actually the
subdomains rather than the content
themselves and that this is a nice
relatively stable for structure diagram
that comes off that kind of distance
measure waiting with no taxonomy
information applied to it the coloring
is the taxonomy and but there was no
taxonomy information applied to this
diagram to get it to here and you see
some very tightly clustered ones the
light green at the bottom right there is
fruit content but you see other ones are
fairly scattered around and you have
some very strong overlapped and so what
happened when we rolled to that
engagement on recommendations doubled so
it worked which was nice and we
consistently beat our own editors and
writers hands down which was just
personally very satisfying and
entertaining and because the one thing
you get in a big editorial organization
is the only campus we do that we're not
all the algorithms run right on this we
did on the old site now we're launching
we launched very well in April we
launched a large finance site a couple
of weeks ago we're launching a tech site
in the middle of October each of which
is top 10 top 15 in the US and now the
entirety of all recirculation counter
recommendation on all the sites is
entirely powered by algorithms of the
sciences team is written and and we've
beaten every personalized recommendation
system that we tested against who are
all trying to get user by user and so we
can understand the behavior of life
populations right the intern is very
good
telling us bulk somewhat stereotypical
but but actually pulling out big signals
from big populations like the statistics
of the internet is inordinately powerful
when you look at everyone and what
they're doing allows us to look state by
statements and what the predictive into
a start by state where all the states
really interesting in an election year
we can do it by city and we can do for
the country as a whole book now by
demographics we can also understand the
behavior of an individual who's on the
site right now we know what options
we've given them we can come out the
probability we're going we iterate and
improve on top of that the signals that
we have we cannot understand what that
person is back in and of themselves with
their decision-making process of the
places of like an article a month they
read over the course of the last year to
even think that that were possible would
be remarkable lots of ad companies
Internet companies tech companies
absolutely take that approach but even
in a world where your Facebook and you
see people on your site every day day in
day out you see their engage with
everything you see how long they hover
over things you know the information
they provided the under the social
network you still don't know the phone
call that they just got five minutes ago
before they went on to the internet
because they've just been told that
father died right you don't know that
information if you know that it's their
father's birthday and you go surface
that information to them because you're
damn sure that's who they are that's not
going to go well for you the certainly
not going to go well for them it's
definitely not going to go well on a
health site we don't know the reason
that got you to our health site today
and we had to fight pretty hard to make
sure that our editors in our teams and
the health on it we're aware that we are
never going to know that information so
we need to build the site with that lack
of knowledge and it's not like a
knowledge that we can fix it's a lack of
knowledge we will always have and have
that top of mind when designing for
people coming into the site and we
visited the last two fun-sized wrote
that was a conversion so there's two
more yet just just for entertainment and
it turns out when you listen to our
users and you have this level of data
you can learn quite a lot so in this
case this is actually our writers
telling us the informations the content
they produce the topic video discusses
NT tagged finance content and going back
to 2001 and this is occurrences of the
entities foreclosure derivative
in credit default swap mortgage-backed
security super subprime having and
Lehman and you can see activists I was
ramping up in mid-2006 at green 2007 and
rising up it turns out the other thing
we spot is you can actually see a spike
in interest in budget cooking and budget
recipes of doubles when Lehman falls and
has only started relaxing after 2015 so
even though all the other economic
indicators are looking very healthy that
unemployment rate is going well and
hassled income and start and derives the
interest of the people have in cooking
cheap recipes and budgeting their
dinners has stayed at a double the
expected level for the last seven years
and and what we do if we have we're in a
broader group more run data science for
investopedia as well as a couple of
other companies you can take into some
particular topics and see whether or not
it Carlos to real-world indices so in
this case this is an anxiety index so
the blue line here is the economic
anxiety of the US as measured by
interest in particular stock and trading
terms 100 is somewhat the baseline here
and you can see clear in this graph that
correlate to actual negative movements
in the market and the red line here is
the Vics now as I measured the
volatility in the markets sometimes the
fix proceeds the anxiety in dexter the
red piece here is brexit right the
country was fairly suave of our exit and
think it's going to be a thing like that
happens you see the blue line jump up
the markets are a little shaky
beforehand but they also jump up on the
same day right this is an external event
that causes both these metrics to meet
at the same time for other measures
towards the end of last year the anxiety
MX was significantly elevated well
before the markets actually spiked in
early January and when we've gone and
done a back testing across four years of
daily data in here and run trading
strategies against the sp500 you
significantly outperform those
strategies when you take into account a
publisher's investment page view data
which is a rather than to anything to be
able to do know when you say okay well
we have a lot of Korea's content we have
a lot of resume content we can look at
this in terms of predicting the
unemployment
rate rather than waiting for those
statistics come out you could have a
daily expected measure we have a lot of
pregnancy contents you can start
predicting breath death rates we have a
lot of like the flu map the Google put
out a long time ago is the first version
of this kind of project and but we can
certainly do it with the data that we
have and cs2 complete it's very very
hard to understand an individual person
but it is extremely report or understand
an entire country using publisher data
thank you